oder was geht ab hier soll mag zum
beispiel heute eine runde weiter und wir
haben einen hersteller warum haben wir
allein herr steffens fragen stellen
lassen was für eine dumme frage
eigentlich wollte ich den anderen
spielmodus aufnehmen weil ich dachte oh
man nicht schon wieder getan aber ihr
kennt mich ja und ich spiele sehr gerne
getan und nachdem ich gestern gestern
mit einer change gebracht habe dass mir
bringt heute guetta und ohne challenge
mit einem typ der von the secret world
heftiger feierte gekehrt zu meinem wir
haben herr staeck late night ding und
start der frage gestellt und beelitz vor
muss geht ok als erstes schon mal
richtigen brocken wie würdest du
reagieren wenn luca als fee verkleidet
in dein zimmer stimmen würde
irgendwo da drüben es die tür
jetzt geht die tür auf wahrscheinlicher
scheint ein wahrer sketche und dann ein
motzkus
das könnte man zeichnet wenn irgendwann
für euch junge ich will keine viel
kostüm sehen
zumindest müsste sich um den küssen aber
ich will sehen dass er ausgeht der
nächste frage mit wem wie fühlst du
silvester 18 erstliga abgegangen ich
fahre silvester mit meiner freunde mit
meinem bruder und ein paar kumpels die
wahrscheinlich auch unterwegs sind mit
uns vielleicht immer noch im keller
vielleicht muss man auch dazu sagen dass
es halb elf ist und also am wohlgemerkt
am 30.12 und wir noch nicht wissen wo
wir morgen endgültig silvester feiern ja
das sagt viel über uns aus logischer
ldap
ich sehe schon so eine frage wie die
palo gefreut wie steht ihr das gesehen
der letzte film den ich gesehen habe war
petric freien von 50 cent weil ich habe
meinen gangster ein bisschen gepustet in
dem ich mal und kathrein zusammen
geschafft habe
ich war so voll angesteckt von von die
hessen austreten konnten weil ihr müsst
wissen ich fall diese thematik flügel
und genauso dieses gangs zeugs und
deshalb war das einfach irgendwie von
point für mich und deshalb habe ich mir
da die beiden filme an einem angezogen
ya yeah yeah yeah war es stefan judisch
bienefeld könntest du dir vorstellen mit
youtube wie zb at congo after etc eine
wg zu ziehen
auf jeden fall fertig eigentlich gut wie
blut in eine wohnung ziehen ja
grundsätzlich mit mit youtube mann in
der wohnung zu ziehen ist ist eine coole
vorstellen dazu für nachdem er ihnen mit
rat zu nach dem abi ist es auf jeden
fall glaube ich eine sache wenn man so
sich sowieso auf youtube fokussieren
will dann ist natürlich schon wieder alt
es passiert schon wieder junge was ist
das hey leute ich habe ich zu viel glück
oder passiert euch das auch von ihr ich
kriegte schon wieder alles was zur hölle
ist das motto the place pigalle tonto
auswahl alter schwede was war das gerade
eben fühlen das hatte ich ja schon mal
ja das wollte das war dieses video als
perfekter start
ja das war perfekt ich könnte mir nichts
oder vorstellig letzten gut gespielt
aber so was
danke also ein video schafft bitte unter
brüdern
nächste frage man ja ich gucke erzähl
mir was über kompletter im märchen
erreichen über komplexe okay es war
einmal ein komplott der hatte an seinen
frau gefallen da ja auch gut so
android oder ios eine sehr tiefe frage
sagt neue frage oder zehnfach gestellt
ich persönlich also gut die frage
bezieht sich jetzt ausschließlich auf
das betriebssystem da kann ich eindeutig
apple sagen also os x betriebssystem
meilen but mine besser finde ich hatte
also apple machte deutlich ich hatte
noch nie ein android-gerät ich hatte
schon windows phone und ich hatte auch
schon android geräte update windows
phone ja beides absoluter modern echt ja
finde ich finde ich schon
also da musste ich allen anderen fans
leider sagen dass ich euren chat support
1620 punkte lässt sich drehen leute das
ist obgleich im ganzen leben es ist auch
konferieren okay jetzt auch abgefragt
was sind deine neujahrsvorsätze oder
hast du so was überhaupt
neujahrsvorsätze sind so eine sache
finde ich nicht so super also ich denke
mir ich brauche kein neuer für vorletzte
und dementsprechend mache ich mir
eigentlich auch nicht groß welche gibt
natürlich sachen die ich in der nächsten
zeit umsetzen will aber das sind alles
sachen die in der nächsten zeit umsetzen
will und ich irgendwelche kranken
vorsätze die ich endlich schaffen muss
gott ich hab' ich habe glaube ich kann
in vier perfekt in die gasse stop alter
aber ja ich habe auch wenn die
enchantment immer so krankengeld das ist
so glaube ich relativ safe gewonnen
ja klar die ja ich hab auch noch extra
herzen gekocht ja wie viel
vier extra herzen raps 4,4 und empfindet
ja
kunden könnten sie eventuell an dich
gehen man weiß es eventuell an der
alfred haben wir die fragen der bürger
fragt hast du irgendeine seltsame
angewohnheit ja ich weiß nicht ob das
manchen von euch aufgefallen ist aber
was mir da spontan einfällt ist ich
spiele immer an meinen ohren rum das
liegt daran dass ich meine ordnung so
lustig abstellen kann und die klappen
irgendwann zurück und ich kann lustige
dinge mit meinen ohren machen und das
mache ich viel zu häufig dass ich
irgendwann meinen ohren rumpf ich jetzt
gar keine dinge dass indikationen
geschichte aber dass schon das abwasser
seit ewigkeiten seitdem so ganz kleines
früher müsst ihr wissen ich hab' ich
habe lange am deutlichen gelutscht und
gewinn an bord oder an dem der xbox
world kommt auch alle auf mich alter
alter schwede
die helden egal infiniti regeln oder
vier regelt wie gut ich gebe ihm ein
ganz gutes klar ja auf jeden fall folge
presse würde drei leute auf mich kam hab
ich noch ganz gut regeln können das war
früher megastar mit einer hand so an
seinem ohr um gespielt
ich muss da muss man kühlen aus war
wegert das war ich nur sagen kühlen
musstest du ja macht er das so
die kinder ja ja man könnte also mit der
andrang beim org hüllt man also der
anderen könnten
wirklich ich bin ewig lange noch so wenn
wir irgendwie durch die stadt gefahren
sind oder so was habe ich das echt ewig
lange noch gemacht dass ich irgendwie am
deutschen habe das war auf jeden fall
volles programm immer der rega den haben
wir doch kein verkehr gesperrt neben
schlechter komisch warum nicht runter
und sprach wiederholt
wir müssen zurück ins wasser als andere
die anderen haben ja klar
die anderen jungs haben auch gold apple
ist es natürlich auch eine sache
dank meinem homburg franz der natürlich
alle bemerken waren oder bemerkenswerten
taktiken vorgestellt hatte von wegen 15
gold äpfel kaufen und dann sich hoch
hasselmann am equipment sind natürlich
viele leute gut aufgestellten eine hatte
auch definitiv schon der der urlaub
schon in den diensten von franz renner
als ver - tut kann auf jeden fall aus
tekken wenn ihr geld anbietet feiert
geht auch nicht alle auf mich verfluchte
scheiße sollte ich mal schocken
das richtig krank ist geht nicht voran
geht fragen was richtig krank es richtig
krank gibt okay also junge jetzt jetzt
ins intranet nördlingens sagt es gibt
eine ff in der luca dich mit melonen
vögelt solltest du sie wahr machen
ich würde so etwas denken sich ertl aus
ich würde
ich alle schlagen diesen scheiß
schreiben ist nutzt klickt entwürfen
sowas liest dann kriegt man einfach nur
angst
der tod hat glaube ich kein klasse
geholt ich habe hier auch dirigenten
kann mir serie betten er hat diese gold
ab die taktik macht brauche ich hab's
wieder weggeworfen aber ich glaube das
war noch eine ganze menge
und der war schon die ganze zeit
gefunden und ehrte franz gehring ja 63
gold noch der fan kann schon gut sein
dass er das gemacht hat zwei spieler
leben noch den letzten rest auch noch
unter beiers rausgehen e-mail glaubst du
an karma also glaubst du daran dass das
alle das wieso man sagen oder
gerechtigkeit ins jahr in dem eine art
übergeordnete gerechtigkeit gibt die
schlechte taten mit schlechten nein mit
mittel mit pech für dich vergällt das
glaub ich nicht vergeht ich habe kein
konstrukt anders ich glaube was mir in
lahde live hassel erklärt aber leute ich
würd sagen wir suchen einfach mal
letzten typen die verkämpfen sich so
gerne erforschen
ja was immer ein großer rückhalt keine
chance keine chance hat wahrscheinlich
über excel herzen leiter des instituts
so und freunde ich hoffe euch hat die
runde gefallen
ich fand es eigentlich cool war sehr
flottes der get down bad also drag
racing bad und sonst und die fragen man
auch cool von daher ist es verdammt spät
passiert wahrscheinlich wir sehen uns
dann morgen wieder und auf dass es ein
bisschen früh ist